bonsoir messieurs merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous sur rt france pour débattre
première question pour vous jean
françois jeanneau viac ça fait une
semaine que les français sont confinés
ce qu'on peut déjà mesurer les effets de
cette mesure dans la loire très peu nous
sommes extrêmement impacté comme l'était
le grand test lors de la première vague
je pense qu'il va falloir attendre
encore les trois semaines qui viennent
pour pouvoir voir si ce confinement un
intérêt et surtout si la population a
compris qu'en plus du confinement il
faut respecter gestes-barrières c'est à
dire porter un masque se laver les mains
avec du gel hydroalcoolique et éviter le
plus possible les relations avec
d'autres personnes jean-paul à nous on a
beaucoup entendu effectivement que ce
confinement était plus souple que celui
de mars dernier
vous pensez qu'il aurait fallu un
confinement plus plus dur et quels sont
pour vous les premières retombées de ce
confinement
il faut il faut attendre encore une
bonne semaine pour pour savoir si si ça
a une efficacité et si la courbe se
stabilise en moyenne c'est ça on dit
qu'il faut 15 18 jours après une action
pour voir son effet donc de toute façon
je suis d'accord avec mon confrère 1 et
en plus il faut il faut ouvrir les
fenêtres et il puise à l'intérieur mais
c'est ça au sein et au sein des familles
être extrêmement prudent parce que bon
on a le sentiment que quand on rentre
chez soi qu'on est entre nous on peut on
peut se relâcher seulement bon à
l'intérieur il ya des gens qui viennent
de l'extérieur et qui peuvent
transporter de virus donc il faut rester
prudent à l'intérieur on a vu que le
les les familles il y avait des cas
groupés à l'intérieur des familles tout
autant que qu'à l'école tout autant que
quand l'entreprise donc il faut être
prudent il faut être prudent chez soi
aussi
mais justement je reste avec vous jean
paul hamon ces mesures sont un peu
critiqués parce que justement les
personnes fragiles sont les plus
vulnérables forcément et elles sont
toujours confinés à l'intérieur de leur
famille donc potentiellement contaminés
à bhl est ce qu'on n'a pas on ne sait
pas un peu trompé sur la méthode le
gouvernement d'ailleurs mon visage
maintenant peut-être un confinement plus
strictes pour les personnes vulnérables
écoutez c'est pas facile c'est pas
facile de gouverner en ce moment vous
savez on a bon on a eu on a eu au départ
où tout départ on a eu du retard sur les
masques au mois de septembre on a eu du
retard sur les tests bon maintenant je
pense que tous on est on est à peu près
équipés en masques et en test
l'atout tout va dépendre de la de la
rigueur que vont mettre les français à
respecter les mesures barrières que ce
soit au travail dans les transports à
l'école ou en famille c'est tout inclus
les pans de sa vie dans les transports
c'est compliqué jean françois jeanneau
via que vous êtes d'accord est ce que la
méthode a été la bonne ou est ce qu'on
aurait pu faire mieux
donc c'est toujours facile de dire qu'on
peut faire mieux surtout quand on n'a
pas les manettes et c'est surtout ceux
qui n'ont pas les manettes qui peuvent
dire qu'ils auraient pu faire mieux
comme le dit jean paul hamon il faut
faire très attention un certain nombre
de nos citoyens de nos collègues font
très attention dans le cadre de leur
profession dans le cadre de leur travail
mais effectivement la contamination va
se faire au moment où les personnes qui
vont travailler vont aller prendre un
café ou vont manger ou quand lorsqu'on
rentre dans sa famille on a eu des
connexions avec d'autres personnes à
l'extérieur et on va oublier ses gestes
barrières parce qu'on est dans le cadre
familial et là on va se contaminer on va
contaminer les autres et on va
contaminer éventuellement les personnes
fragiles que l'on va côtoyer dans le
cadre familial nous les professionnels
de santé
on est extrêmement prudents vis-à-vis
des patients fragiles on en voit tous
les jours
mais lorsque nous sommes dans la vie
d'un citoyen lambda
il faut aussi que nous ayons c'est
de protection vis-à-vis de nous-mêmes et
surtout de notre entourage de nos
familles et des gens qu'on côtoie et qui
sont aussi des gens fragiles comment est
ce que vous expliquez que la france soit
le pays qui est qui est le plus de cas
de contamination est ce que c'est parce
qu'elle est massivement ou est-ce que ça
s'explique autrement oui je pense que
effectivement plus plus nous testerons
plus nous trouverons de cas peut-être
que nous étions déjà mauvais lors de la
première vague mais nous ne restions que
les gens qui étaient censés être malade
donc les chiffres qui nous était donnée
était ce qui était vraiment malade
aujourd'hui les patients au appris à
revenir vers leur médecin traitant en
ville a commencé à parler de leurs
symptômes dès le début nous nous nous
nous nous allons les tester le plus
rapidement possible maintenant restera
le le test est fait reste le problème de
l' isolement moment isolée des gens qui
sont testés et pour protéger
l'entourage de ces gens qui sont testés
ça reste une question que nous avons
abordé en partie cet après midi avec le
premier ministre lorsqu'il est venu nous
rendre visite au chu de saint-etienne
et voilà est justement la question des
hôtels qui avait été évoqué initialement
n'avait pas marché est ce que c'est
s'est remis sur la table je reste avec
vous jean françois jeanneau génolhac
vient écouter on peut prendre le modèle
comme nous l'avons fait de la corée du
sud mais est ce que chacun des français
accepteraient d'avoir son téléphone
d'avoir une connexion est d'avoir une
surveillance de où il est et ce qu'il
fait en permanence
il faut aussi que les français prennent
en conscience que cette maladie n'est
pas celle des autres c'est aussi la leur
elle peut toucher des gens qui leur sont
proches et que finalement si dans notre
société seul le coronavirus existait ce
ne serait qu'un épiphénomène l'hôpital
et l'ensemble des soignants s'en
occuperait mais il faut faire attention
à toutes les autres pathologies à
protéger tous les autres qui peuvent
avoir un infarctus qui peuvent avoir un
accident de la route qui peuvent avoir
d'autres pathologies
les isoler par quels moyens il faut
peut-être voir avec des hôteliers est ce
qu'ils sont intéressés
est-ce qu'ils doivent être
réquisitionnés ça ça dépasse je crois le
choix et la positionnement le
positionnement des soignants je pense
que jean paul hamon sera devant de mon
avis il appartient aux pouvoirs
politiques de prendre les décisions
nécessaires pour que ceux qui sont
positifs puis 7 isoler correctement dans
de bonnes conditions mais je pense que
plus on testera plus on trouvera de
patients malades et si on trouve des
malades il faut que les pouvoirs publics
trouvent une solution pour les obliger à
ceux à s'isoler et à ne pas contaminer
les autres
jean paul hamon alors vous êtes d'accord
avec ça que faire le gouvernement est ce
qu'il faut déjà penser aux déconfinement
est anticipée c'est ce qu'on reproche
aussi au gouvernement le manque
d'anticipation parfois écoutez là
franchement ce serait difficile
d'anticiper quoi que ce soit
là visiblement les mesures qui ont été
prises sont des mesures qui sont
raisonnables on va dire pour raisonnable
pour l'économie raisonnable pour tenter
de
de maintenir le système de santé hors de
l'eau et de ne pas être débordé donc
tout est une question de dosage entre un
confinement sévère qui pourrait
effectivement freiner complètement
l'épidémie mais qui mettrait l'économie
complètement à genoux
et puis et puis aller vers aussi cette
immunité collective dont tout le monde
rêve mais mais qui n'est qui n'est pas
facile à favre donc mais les chiffres
les chiffres sont assez importants jean
paul hamon d'ailleurs mon papa était de
toutes les volontés de son père ne sont
pas exacts il y aurait davantage de cas
mais les chiffres pour l'instant connu
quelques couacs
il ya certainement il ya certainement
davantage de cas mais même si
actuellement bon test on teste
massivement il ya des gens qui sont très
très surpris d'être déclaré positif
alors qu'ils ne présentent aucun
symptôme est et ils sont certainement
pas seul vous savez il ya des gens qui
il ya des gens qui ce test il y en a
beaucoup il ya les gens qui ne sont pas
testés et qui sont malades et c'est ça
toute la difficulté de ce 2 7 de cette
épidémie de laisser des gens dans la
nature qui contamine joyeusement les
lecteurs leurs collègues et je pense
sincèrement vous savez on a fermé les
restaurants on devrait fermer les
cantines scolaires on devrait fermer les
cantines d'entreprises parce que vous
vous contaminer largement autant dans
des cantines d'entreprise homme éconduit
scolaire que dans des restaurants et
bien souvent bien plus parce que les
cantines les cantines scolaires
c'est difficile de faire respecter les
mesures barrières et donc il faut il
faut inventer quelque chose pour limiter
au maximum les contaminations sur les
lieux de travail et dans les écoles donc
si je vous suis bien j'en peu l'amour
finalement quand on a un masque et qu'on
respecte les distances on comptait mines
pas et on ne se fait pas contaminé c'est
bien là la clé du problème
oui et puis et puis aussi bien qu'on
arrive dans des dans des périodes qui
vont être froide il faut penser à bien
aérer les pièces régulièrement pour
faire circuler le virus ait essayé de
virer des pièces c'est ça qui est très
important à ne faire aucune réunion là
j'ai vu encore quelques cas dans une
dans une entreprise où il y avait une
entreprise qui avait fait une réunion
avec 18 personnes dans une pièce qui
devait pas faire 25 mètres carrés avec
des gens qui portaient le masque plus ou
moins bien il y avait deux personnes
contaminées qui ne le savaient pas ça
fait si c'est peut-être bien 8
au bout du compte donc il faut être
extrêmement prudent et tout le temps
jean françois jeanneau diack vous êtes
d'accord avec ça ce deuxième confinement
est plutôt équilibré entre l' vies
humaines et la vie économique
moi j'ai envie de dire que c'est pas
forcément la position des médecins qui
doivent choisir si l'économie doit être
devant la santé en tout cas et on grave
pour la saluer aussi nous savons touche
c'est l'économie qui financera la santé
donc si nous avons une bonne économie et
de toute façon si nous avons des
citoyens en bonne santé l'économiste
portera mieux pour rebondir un tout
petit peu sur ce que disait jean paul
hamon est ce que sur ce que vous disiez
sûr sur cette protection collective
les premières études qui semble arriver
montre que les anticorps de quelqu'un
qui a été malade ne reste pas très
longtemps donc c'est peut-être une des
raisons qui va expliquer que nous allons
avoir une deuxième vague j'aurais bien
aimé dire une seconde vague et
malheureusement j'ai peur que ce soit
une deuxième vague et que derrière cette
deuxième vague il y en a peut-être
d'autres
ce qui voudra dire que le jour nous
avons un vaccin il faudra sûrement qu'on
est plusieurs doses de vaccin à temps
afin d'atteindre des anticorps qui nous
soit protecteur et longtemps protecteur
donc ne comptons pas sur cette immunité
collective
comptant sur le bon sens de la
population et des français ils ont
compris qu'il faut se protéger quand on
porte un masque pour ne contaminent pas
les autres quand on porte un masque on s
on ne se contaminent pas quand on est
malade on reste chez soi on se nettoie
bien les mains et surtout on essaye
d'avoir des relations sociales des plus
petit possible quand je dois rencontrer
quelqu'un est-ce que c'est absolument
nécessaire si la réponse est oui je le
fais si la réponse est non je reste chez
moi
le propre du confinement est du domaine
des pouvoirs publics et je pense que la
fin je n'ai pas personnellement à donner
mes conseils aux pouvoirs publics
qui décide en fonction de ce que leur
disent le comité des médecins auxquels
ils se sont rapprochés ils président de
la république l'a fait nous pouvons
donner notre avis et je pense qu'il faut
que la population se protège si la
population ne se protège pas même avec
un confinement ça ne fonctionnera pas
gestes-barrières à respecter en toutes
circonstances même au sein de la famille
merci beaucoup jean françois jeanneau
via quai et merci à vous jean paul hamon
d'avoir participé à ce débat sur rt
france merci merci à vous